dans les années 50
un français sur trois a les moyens de
partir en vacances
partir c'est le verbe que paris à
conjuguer pendant les quatre premiers
jours du mois d' des portes encombrées
de voitures au gaz encombré de voyageurs
2 millions de parisiens s'évader du
quotidien les froncés s'évade par la
route du soleil la nationale 7 qui file
tout droit vers le littoral ou par le
train options économiques avec les
billets populaire qui permettent aux
plus modestes de prendre le large et
pour les plus fauchés reste l'auto-stop
l'organisation la plus classique qui
fait appel à des techniques éprouvées
reste encore payant qu'il faut bien le
vivre
une fois à destination il suffit de
planter sa tente
le camping c'est les vacances rêvées des
années 60 comme le raconte angèle six
mois les vacances c'est le camping ce
qu'il me faut c'est la nature à les
numéros 12 la 37e tente sur la gauche
une petite bleue juste après les deux
grandes zones et puis tout est organisé
depuis trop le mans vient en plus tu
comprends tu es libre tu complètement
avait pas d'enfants dans les années 70
un nouveau type de vacances a de plus en
plus de succès le club de vacances c'est
dans des cases sans eau sans électricité
bâti à même le sable ouvert à tous et à
toutes avec deux lits jumeaux des
planches pour les vêtements que le
gentiment va jouer les bons sauvages
leur journée commence à 8h heure du club
et le premier bruit du moteur
j'ai beaucoup de collègues qui disent
par exemple je ne comprends pas que vos
communes tarn et moi je préfère
organiser mes vacances bonjour guillou
organise toute l'année voit le club les
highness pour moi je préfère le club à
la même époque c'est l'arrivée des
charters ses avions affrétés par des
agences de voyages moins cher que les
vols réguliers
démocratise le transport aérien face à
cette nouvelle concurrence les grandes
compagnies les critiques c'est la
première fois que nous partons aux
amériques évidemment vous allez me dire
mais bien sûr vous n'avez pas le droit
au fameux gueuleton dîner et cetera pour
vous offre d'habitude sur air france bon
bah ça fait rien on veut bien nous faire
un petit pique nique c'est amusant une
fois n'est pas coutume aujourd'hui les
critiques émises contre le tourisme de
masse ou le transport aérien donneront
peut-être envie à certains de revenir
aux fondamentaux des années sans comptes
auto stop et compile
[Musique]